exactly one year ago hurricane Michel
blew away homes and businesses in parts
of Florida well we're returning this
morning to see how the lives of
Michael's victims have changed the
deadly storm barreled into the Florida
Panhandle with wind speeds of more than
150 miles an hour the hurricane is
blamed for 16 deaths and about 25
billion dollars of damage in the US
Manuel Bojorquez is in Mexico Beach
Florida the town Michael hit the hardest
man well how is it doing today
well good morning you can see some of
these destroyed buildings have barely
been touched but nearby
there are some signs of new life and
homes under construction though Mexico
Beach still lacks many of the basics to
this day this community does not have a
gas station a bank or even a grocery
store the category 5 hurricane barreled
into Mexico Beach Florida last October a
year later reminders of the deadly storm
are everywhere so a year ago
that's just look exactly that has not
changed nothing al Kathy runs the local
hardware store and has been mayor here
for 15 years
you know when 75% of your city is
destroyed things aren't going to happen
quickly in a year there is clearly
progress but people here say insurance
payouts have been slowed and dealing
with government red tape is frustrating
1200 lived here before the storm now
it's just around 400 it's been a lot of
lows in the very beginning the last six
months we you know got a little clicking
our heels but a nearby panama city
hundreds still live in FEMA trailer
parks more than 2400 Bay district school
kids are listed as displaced or homeless
and Tyndall Air Force Base a major
employer has spent 700 million on
repairs but still has more to do how's
that go better today
Trudy white and her husband relocated to
Florida after losing everything in
Hurricane Katrina their occasion
restaurant on Panama City Beach avoided
a direct hit from
but many of her employees weren't so
lucky what has been the biggest hurdle
to recovery here keeping the employees a
lot of people lost our homes in town and
they had to move away because they
didn't have any place to live the people
who were able to stay looking for a new
place lived the rent went sky-high for
everybody back on Mexico Beach
Jessica SH work is general manager at
Mango Marlies which is still operating
out of a food truck but she says the
tide here has begun to turn when I would
see people at first we would cry and hug
and it's still nice to see them but it's
a little more normal you know we're
feeling it's sad but this is kind of
just our new normal you know this is the
new normal
most days we don't even think about the
hurricane really and despite that
progress clearly there is a long way to
go here before hurricane Michael between
houses apartments and condos there were
27 hundred units here now barely five
hundred of those are livable Tony so
glad we're sticking with this story
incredible pictures there Manny thank
you very much